What do you think about tributer and supreme?
Or scribe for me to help with leaky gut issues, I think?
Let's answer that question first.
So the tributer and supreme and other buterin products are the main endpoint fuel stage for
your gut cells. So that's how you heal your gut.
Now, you will be making your own muterate from indigestible fiber.
So if you're eating a fiber product, you're taking sunscreen or sun fiber or you're eating foods
with fiber in it, you're making your own muterate to feed your gut cells.
But if somebody with a really damaged leaky gut, it's always really good to start with a
muterate product. So a muterate product is a good thing to use.
To help heal the gut, it gives instant fuel to help heal your epithelial cells.
Second part of this question. Also, L5MTHFR, since I think the chiropractor thinks I need
folate according to his muscle testing. I have multiple videos where cancer patients do not want to
use methyl groups. So L5MTHFR is a very strong methyl group and you can be turned off to
suppressor genes by taking that. Besides the fact that you can be pushing your biopter and path,
you will be pushing your biopter and path very strongly. So I know that a lot of chiropratars
are really big into a lot of naturopaths are really big into taking methyl tetrahedral folate as a
product. And they're ignoring a couple big pictures. Even if a person doesn't have a diagnosis
of cancer, you have to look genetically at a person's biopter pathway. If they have defects in their
comp genes, they're MOA genes, they're GAN genes, you're going to push that pathway quite strongly
and your risk having some mood issues and comp issues with breast cancer are a real thing as well.
That's a risk factor right there. So I'm not a big fan of doing
methyl tetrahedral folate. The only caveat to that is if a person has elevated homocysteine
and he can't get their homocysteine levels down, then using some methyl groups to get the homocysteine
groups down would be an appropriate call to action. But just because it's coming up under muscle
test today, I would be careful of that. And then when you have cancer as a diagnosis and you're
going to add methyl groups, you're going to be silencing two or suppressor genes. And I'll
guarantee you that 99% of chiropractors and entrepreneurs do not understand that at all. Now, I've created
multiple videos on that and you could go on the website and look, should cancer patients take methyl
groups and I answer that on there and you could have your chiropractor go look at those videos too.
So I would say be careful with that.